our next guests are the stars of the
comedy series it's hilarious it's called
the lake so the show is about Justin
think about this he had a child with his
best friend in high school and gave the
child up for an open adoption okay makes
sense so far years later Justin who has
since come out as a gay man reunites
with his now teenage daughter her name
is Billy to spend a summer together the
two of them stay at the lake in Canada
where Justin spent his Summers growing
up in the newly released season two
Justin and Billy get to spend a second
summer together on the lake here's a
look
we are not talking about my love life
and yours is on fire yes someone was
supposed to help me with that and I
tried but Riley just hit in his room
listening to CB radio all week yeah he's
trolling for accidents really soothes
him
hey will you please please please
consider staying an extra week I'll even
cry for your parents Justin me getting
this internship was a big deal for them
I can't just ditch
a job like this could really help with
scholarships next year you don't need
any help because you're adorable like me
and that's what they do the whole series
Jordan Jordan gavares and Madison
shimoon were happy to say who played
Justin and Billy join us in the studio
good morning to you both good morning
the premise guys was like nothing I've
ever seen when you first read the script
both of you you thought this makes sense
I got to do this role what did you think
oh instantaneous for me how so well or
why so yeah well it was Justin it was
the character I mean on top of the
writing being really sharp and fresh and
uh
just a kind of incisive perspective on
life in general related to him well in
the sense that our showrunner created a
world that wasn't heteronormative and as
a queer person
um the idea of playing someone like
Justin that I shared so much with not
just not just sexuality but just in
general I just saw a lot of myself in
this character I was so thrilled at the
idea that I was going to be able to put
someone on screen that I would have been
I would have I would have killed to see
somebody like Justin on screen what
would the young Justin say yeah like it
was it was a dream and I you know it's
it's always a dream any character you
play is a dream and you you fall in love
with aspects of them but there was just
something that I loved so much about the
fact that Justin's story also wasn't
about his identity it wasn't about his
trauma of coming out so it wasn't about
any of those things it was about the
complexity of trying to connect with his
birth daughter this was this wasn't a
story about trauma or identity crisis it
was a love story yeah it is a love story
that was really exciting to me what
about you Madison yeah I was stoked when
I got the script same thing the writing
was insane but I didn't think that I had
a shot at it because they were telling
me that you know they're going to get
someone in Canada you're in the U.S it's
being shot in Canada it's Canadian
original so I wasn't emotionally
attached to it yet I just kind of put it
on tape and let it go and that was like
in March and then come like June they
were like hey we can't find anyone we
still don't have this girl yet can you
please read the new script put it on
tape I did that they asked me to come
read with you well I had like the read
between the two I love it it was all it
was it was amazing it's the best camera
I've ever also what was it guys what
what made it yeah the two of you yeah
what was it well it was this scene where
I'm saying oh we got to go out climate
change and stuff and you're like oh
that's right season one yeah Justin at
Peak sort of uh bad parent
um but it was even over Zoom which is
actually it was over Zoom it was over
Zoom oh wow
wow pandemic right so the work covid was
still raging and we had to do this this
chem read over zoom and and that's
always tricky because you worry about
delays and just is the connection gonna
be there but yes your magnetism
Madison's magnetism and charm and
it all just like radiated through the
computer screen and I I just fell in
love with you immediately I felt the
same way I was like I don't know if this
is normal but I've never had a chem read
this good before and like Jordan would
pick up where I left off and it felt
like we were finishing each other's
sentences yes
I love it so we really we really lucked
out after that it seems like you've
wanted to do maybe not this particular
role but certainly be in this business
it says when you were 13 you told your
parents you wanted an agent for
Christmas
at 13. my poor dad was like a what and
then I was like put him in a box and
he's like put a purse but what was your
thinking then that I want an agent at
there well I was very serious about it
and I I wasn't kidding like I'd come
home from school and I would watch
movies and I would memorize every line
of like my favorite movies and I'd
reenact them for my parents plays what
weren't those movies like a stepmom with
Julia Roberts Practical Magic like some
good oldies you know and my parents
a moment ago you used the phrase that
Canadian original which you know could
describe you Jordan you know Ontario can
I suppose I'm a Canadian original well
the reason I bring it up is because you
say that this uh this show Nails
Canadian Cottage culture oh does it ever
what is that yeah okay so I didn't I my
family did not own a cottage growing up
but we did have the fortune of getting
to spend time in Cottage Country which
is like our Catskills or the Adirondacks
like it's it's Northern Ontario rustic
living let me tell you something
everything you see in the show this sort
of wet hot American succession of it all
um
it's all real people take Cottage
ownership Cottage lineage very seriously
rules about boat houses Politics on the
lake like to the peop to the people that
have Cottages in these places for those
three or four months of the year that is
what their entire life is about Wayne
and Jane that you know played
brilliantly by John Dora and Natalie
lashinska they're real people I've met
guys well you guys are real because your
Chemistry on screen is exactly what
we're seeing here okay great but we
always say this we're like our
characters are a bit of us and we're a
bit of them yeah so it worked out that
way amplifier we'll just say this happy
for you both I love that suit thank you
you always look good Jordan thank you so
much for coming getting up early because
we know that's a pain season two of the
lake is available now on Amazon Prime
video and